لمعرفة المزيد عن آخر الأخبار، انضم إليّ يان
إيغان، الأمين العام
للمجلس النرويجي للاجئين الذي لديه
العديد من الموظفين على الأرض في
غزة، وقد أمضى وقتًا طويلاً في محاولة
بناء طريق للسلام في هذه المنطقة
من الصعب حتى تخيله  تلك
المحادثة الآن أم يان
كانت الميسر الرئيسي في
المفاوضات التي أدت إلى اتفاقيات أوسلو للسلام
في
عام 1993 أم يان، لقد رأيت كل شيء أم يان، هناك
شيء واحد أسمعه دائمًا من جميع
ضيوفنا وهو أنهم لم يروا أي شيء
تمامًا مثل هذا بالحجم الذي
يحدث به كل هذا الآن، أولاً
وقبل كل شيء، اسمحوا لي أن أسألك عن
أداء فريقك على الأرض، هل تم
حسابهم جميعًا، لقد تم
حسابهم جميعًا هذا
الصباح، ونأمل وندعو الله أن يفعلوا ذلك
كن آمنًا أيضًا صباح الغد ولكن الكثير
منهم يفرون للنجاة بحياتهم هؤلاء
هم عمال الإغاثة وهم الآن يساعدون
زملائهم من الغران منذ عقود وهم
يفرون للنجاة بحياتهم أه
الغالبية منهم يعيشون في مدينة غزة
وضواحيها  في الشمال وما
جاءت به إسرائيل أه
أمر مستحيل وغير قانوني
بالتهجير القسري فلا تتحدث عنه كأنه إجلاء
إنساني
هذا ما يوصف خلاله
في اتفاقيات جنيف بالتهجير القسري
إنها حرب  الجريمة حسب
القانون الدولي على إسرائيل أن تبطل
هذا الأمر أه والولايات المتحدة
المملكة المتحدة ألمانيا الاتحاد الأوروبي
كل الدول العربية التي لها تأثير
على إسرائيل يجب أن تجعلهم يبطلون
هذا الأمر المستحيل وغير القانوني أه
سمعنا من وزير الخارجية يومض
ويقطع  في وقت سابق من هذا الصباح حيث
أكد مرة أخرى أنه كان
يتحدث مع نظرائه الإسرائيليين حول
إنشاء نوع من المناطق الآمنة
داخل غزة، هل يمكنك أن تصف لنا
داخل غزة
نفسها هل توجد مناطق آمنة في هذه المنطقة
الآن نظرًا لوجود  هذا
الإخلاء الجماعي عبارة عن مناطق آمنة، حتى
المناطق الآمنة المحتملة ممكنة أه هناك
الكثير من المدارس والمستشفيات بما في ذلك
مكتبنا الخاص في جاسا والذي يُطلب منا الآن
أن ننقل منه وقد تم
تجنب الصراع كما نقول لقد قدمنا
الإحداثيات
للإسرائيليين هذه  إن المدارس والمستشفيات وما إلى
ذلك من مساكن المدنيين
محرمة بموجب القانون الدولي، وعلينا جميعًا
أن نحارب الإرهاب والإرهاب الذي
ضربت إسرائيل به بشكل مروع في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع، لكن لا
تحطموا كل شيء حول
مليون طفل، فهذا سيكون أمرًا
فظيعًا  أيضًا بالنسبة لأمن إسرائيل على المدى الطويل،
سيكون هناك جيل من
الكراهية هنا، لذا، نظرًا لتاريخك
وخبرتك في هذه المنطقة وفي هذا
الصراع، عندما تحذر إسرائيل
وترسل رسائل لأولئك الموجودين في غزة
للفرار من الجنوب وتكون حماس  إخبارهم
بالبقاء في مكانهم في نهاية المطاف، من
المسؤول عن سلامة
الفلسطينيين لأنك توافق على ذلك،
أتصور أن لإسرائيل الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسها، ومن الواضح أنها
شرعت في مهمتها لتدمير خلايا حماس
الإرهابية
نعم والعالم.  القانون
واضح جدًا والعديد من الدول تتعرض
لهجوم إرهابي، العديد من الدول تذهب
لملاحقة إرهابييهم، تأخذهم،
تأخذ تمويلهم، تأخذ أسلحتهم،
أنت أه لقد وصفت أنه كان هناك
فرق تذهب لإطلاق سراح الرهائن
وتأخذ أه الإرهابي الذي هو  ما
تفعله الدول الأخرى لتحطيم مدن مدنية بأكملها
هو أمر غير متناسب، إنه
انتهاك للقانون الدولي
وليس في مصلحة أه إسرائيل،
نحن جميعًا نريد الآن
إطلاق سراح الرهائن أيضًا، وأنا أناشد
ذلك باستمرار على Arrow  وسائل الإعلام الناطقة
والتي أعلم أن حماس تستمع إليها دعونا
نعمل جميعًا من أجل رؤية وقف لإطلاق النار
الآن لقد مات الكثير من الأطفال،
لذا لمزيد من المعلومات عن كل هذا،
انضم إليّ الأمين العام
لمجلس اللاجئين النرويجي يان إيغوند الموجود
في أوسلو  النرويج كان يتحدث إلى
فريقه الموجود على الأرض في غزة يان
إيغان مرحبًا بعودتك
أعني أنك من المحاربين القدامى يؤسفني أن أقول عن الكثير من
هذه المواقف المروعة فيما
يتعلق بالإنسانية كيف تتوقع
دولة  هو إعلان الحرب على
هجوم قاتل قادر
على حماية المدنيين كيف برأيك كيف
سيتكشف، أعتقد أنه
وضع مروع سيكون أسوأ بكثير
في
الأيام المقبلة نعم لقد بدأ مع الإرهاب،
ليس هناك طريقة أخرى ل  قم بوصف الرجال الذين
يدخلون إسرائيل ويقتلون المدنيين
بالمئات كما فعلوا، ولكن الآن هناك
حصار على جميع السكان، هناك
2.4 مليون شخص في غزة، إنه
ليس مثل أي مكان آخر على وجه الأرض، فهم محشورون
معًا في منطقة صغيرة
أصغر من مساحة الأرض.  بلدية أوسلو
حيث أجلس مليون من أصل 2.4
مليون طفل، ثم
يعلنون الآن أن الموقع الإسرائيلي
سيقطع الطعام والماء
والوقود والكهرباء، وسوف يرقى ذلك إلى مستوى جرائم حرب
إذا كان الأطفال سيتضورون جوعًا و و و و
و يموتون  في المستشفيات بسبب
نقص الكهرباء على سبيل
المثال، كما تعلمون، ارتكبت حماس جرائم حرب
ضد المدنيين
داخل إسرائيل مع ذبح
الأبرياء هناك، بالتأكيد ما الذي
تسمعونه من
فرقكم الفعلية على
الأرض ما أسمعه؟  على أرض
50 أه من عمال الإغاثة الشجعان داخل
غازا أنهم يريدون بشدة
بدء أعمال الإغاثة للأرامل مع
الأطفال الذين فقدوا شققهم
بسبب
القصف المكثف لكن لا نستطيع في ظل
خطة القصف العشوائية أه
وتنفيذ أعمال الإغاثة أه  نحن بحاجة إلى بعض
الهدوء ولهذا السبب أؤيد الدعوة إلى إنشاء
ممرات إنسانية، ينبغي أن يأتي
كلاهما من إسرائيل التي أعلنت أنها
لا تريد قتل الأطفال، ولا
تريد تجويع الأطفال، لذا دعونا ننشئ
ممرات إنسانية، ثانيًا، نحتاج إلى
مناطق آمنة حيثما توجد  لن يكون هناك
قصف حتى مدارس أندرا
تعرضت للقصف بالقرب منها أه
زملائي العديد منهم لديهم
شقق الآن أه متضررة اضطروا إلى الفرار
اضطر عمال الإغاثة إلى الفرار خمسة
هذا الصباح كانوا في
أحياء بأكملها تم الإعلان عنها أه
أهداف الهجوم على
الحي بأكمله واضطروا أيضًا إلى الفرار،
إنه أمر لا يصدق حقًا ما
يحدث أم يان إيجلاند، أعني أن ترتدي
قبعة دبلوماسية للحظة، هل هناك
طريقة تعتقد بها أنه يمكن أن يكون هناك أي
تهدئة بدون علامات الاقتباس
أم أننا كذلك؟  من الواضح أن إسرائيل
ستضطر إلى خوض هذه الحرب
أخيرًا للقضاء على حماس في غزة،
وهل تعتقد أن هذا
ممكن، رقم واحد،
يمكن أن ينتهي العنف
غدًا، يمكن أن تكون هناك محادثات تؤدي
إلى إخراج جميع الرهائن من  بعد
إطلاق سراح إسرائيل، كان آخر
بيان فاضح صادر عن حماس هو أنهم
سيبدأون في قتل الرهائن إذا كان هناك
المزيد من القصف على
الولايات المتحدة، ويتعين على مصر ودول الخليج
التوسط في شيء يمنح ضمانات أمنية
لإسرائيل ولكن أيضًا يوافق على رفع
الحصار، ويأمل البعض أن يكون ذلك ممكنًا.  المستقبل بعض
الاحتمالات لشباب غزة الذين
ليس لهم
أمل أه هم يغذون المرارة في
حيهم بالسياسات التي
يتبعونها الآن منذ سنوات عديدة في 2014
2000 فلسطيني مدني استشهدوا
في القصف الإسرائيلي في ذلك
الوقت كان هناك الكثير  الدم
والعنف لسنوات عديدة بين
الشعبين